[Music]
let's go to sarah in pensacola what's up
sarah
hi um thank you so much of course
thank you for calling what's up
um okay i
um
i don't know i guess i kind of need help
i'm kind of in a place where i feel
stuck i guess um
in my marriage i i really don't know how
um
i don't know if i'm hey
yeah you're him hauling a little bit do
this just get off the edge of the diving
board and then just jump
okay just jump on it okay so um how do i
trust my husband after um
he had an affair with a minor
um
and it's
i mean the girl was literally the age of
my daughter now and so
it's just kind of hard
okay walk me walk me through this
because
my first thought is he's
you don't trust him because he's in jail
so walk me through
well he's not okay but um
okay so this happened a long time ago
this happened in 2006. um okay and the
girl was
um has been
he was on staff at a church and she was
um
around anyway
i get a hunch um
how old was she
she would okay she was either 15 or 16
she had a birthday in there or 16 and
turned 17 so how old was he
23.
okay
we were young but
then how old was he now
um
38
okay
when did you find out about this his
birthday
uh
2018. um
he just kind of one day decided to tell
me and
so you found out about this five years
ago four and a half years ago yeah
yeah i mean i kind of had a you know a
hunch and so i when i confronted him
back then it was um
met with a lot of anger like you know
how could you think that about me and
you know your
blah blah blah anyway terrible wife for
thinking that and it kind of went on
like that
were you all there hold on were y'all
married back when this happened
we were we had she was our babysitter we
had a
little infant
um but
he made her a babysitter
and did he was he is he on staff at some
church back then
he was yeah is he still on staff at a
church now
he actually just lost his job um about a
month ago good good
absolutely good man
um
there's so much here okay
um
golly so much here
let me yeah before i just start lobbing
grenades you tell me you asked your
question how do you trust him now
what what has happened in the last week
or two weeks or three weeks it
made this all bubble up because you've
known about this for five years and if
we're all honest with ourselves you've
known about this for
18 years you've known you knew right so
here we are what's made this like bubble
up to the surface
i don't know i'm not real good at um
letting myself
think about things and so i kind of
the more i've been letting myself think
about the more
i guess angry and grossed out i mean i
become i guess you know with my daughter
being
from that age down to um is it his
daughter as well
yes okay
um
and uh it's just sort of
i don't know
it's getting worse i guess more than
it's getting better i i mean we
counseling all the stuff and actually
our counselor kind of
because we're stuck i guess kind of
wanted said i just need to make up my
mind and you know until then there's
really nothing else he can do
did your counselor report this
because your counselor is a mandatory
reporter for child abuse and there's not
a statute of limitations that i know of
on child abuse
especially in a context where someone
still has access to minors like your
husband has had for the last 15 years as
a on staff minister
so your therapist didn't make a report
no
no
really
yeah i mean i i would recommend um with
all
of my being
that
you either contact a friend who's an
attorney
or you
um
file on this person's license because
they shouldn't be a therapist
at all
because you cannot let this stuff just
roll out
like your husband violated a child he
committed a crime right
yes yes um i mean everything
because i was talking to
my
pastor's wife and um she was just sort
of sam
because he ended up you know telling
them as well and
um that's not actually what
he lost his job they were just making
cuts but um
so they they oh they let him stay like
oh well all right just act better next
time
yeah i mean they did and this isn't the
first church he's been fired from
four
different things like sexual things like
this is the
well this is the second for that but
what are the other sexual things he's
been fired for
um the first one
uh
this is before i think up before i had
our first shot um
it was
something with email sending emails to
the
um to someone in the church and they
linked the emails to his computer which
he still denies all of it
but
that it was him
but
as you're
that you know of and
there's knowing like cognitively like in
your head like facts
and then there's knowing and you're a
wife and a mother
and so you know
you know
has he cheated on you since then
i don't think so i mean what another
piece that graces me out is that not
only was he on staff but he was working
with like youth group like for years
like 10 years i know i know hold on hold
on
but he's not on the phone with me right
now you are
yeah
and
i always want to be respectful and kind
on this show
but i got a little girl sarah
and i've worked with ministers and i
worked behind closed doors with churches
and
my tolerance for this is less than zero
and there was a predator that you had a
hunch about and you said nothing for a
long long time
and so some of this rage and anger that
you have
is at him and it's appropriate
but it's also at the mirror
because now you're looking at a 16 year
old who's in your home
and you're you're
going oh whoa
you know what i mean
yeah and it's hard to wrap your head
around the fact that your husband's a
creep
he's a criminal
and he does not display good judgment
when it comes to
sexuality and
uh stewarding the role he has whether
he's a teacher or a therapist or a
minister there is an elevated
responsibility to
to create incredible gaps
between you and sexual any sort of
sexual feelings towards somebody because
they feel them and it distorts
relationships
and i cannot wrap my head i think the
last number i read was
it's something wild the number of it's
in three figures it's like a hundred or
150 it's some wild number
the amount of time
somebody uh acts out sexually before
they get caught with minors
it's wild i mean it was it was i
couldn't believe it if my friend uh she
she's a researcher into this stuff into
sexual abuse especially particularly
churches i wouldn't have believed it
except that i trust her so much
and so
to answer your original questions you
don't
there's nothing to respect here
yeah um
i'm more concerned that you knew about
this four and a half years ago and you
didn't
send him out the door that second
because you had a 12 year old at the
time i'm concerned that he's still
floating around like
help me with that because i wanna i want
i want to give you say the right thing
that you will look in the mirror and say
what am i doing
and i'm sorry that your church
leadership has failed you so
dramatically
they're they're disgusting and they're
an embarrassment they should not be in
church leadership and i hope that your
senior pastor would i hope he gets fired
too
hope he's gone for allowing this
to continue and continuing to continue
and i'm all about grace and redemption
i'm a that's that's a cornerstone of
this show
but dude i'm not going to put you in a
position to hurt kids it's not
yeah
and i just don't have any quarter for
that man i just don't i've just seen two
i just seen the wake of children man it
just causes so much disaster in people's
lives and families all i have to say is
this
like
what what can i do to help you
to empower you to say whoa
what am i doing here
i don't know i mean because i
i mean as of yesterday you know just
kind of talking to him i'm like look i
i really feel like i need a divorce like
i just can't look at you and
you know be okay like and so
um
i don't
i don't really know what's the hang up
what's like right there what's the
hangout
i mean finances uh you know we have
three kids together um
and it's just sort of
i don't know how to
navigate that
my twin brother offered to
pay for the attorney and everything i'm
just like but you know i don't know how
to go
past that like how to
live
i'm a teacher and so it's just sort of
you know
so
here's here's the best way to look at it
um you're in florida right
um
i grew up in houston so you and i both
have a mutually similar experience which
is hurricanes coming through and just
wiping things out right yeah and we get
a couple of weeks notice and then it
becomes a few days notice and then it's
like oh this is really happening
and
then it becomes a shell game right you
don't know where this thing's going to
land what it's going to hit it'll take
out a neighborhood but not the street i
mean not the houses across the street
right you just don't know okay
what you haven't come to terms with is
that a hurricane has destroyed
everything for you
and there's a
a stupor is the a negative way to say it
there's a shock
when you'll see somebody walking on the
wreckage of a home that's burned down or
that's been it's been knocked down
uh by natural disaster
and they are
like looking for something because they
got to pay a bill
like they just need to find that little
the little folder that had all their
bills because their water bill is going
to come due
and it's like i'm just getting to the
next thing and the next thing and it's
one of those that you got to stop
and just walk out on the street and take
a big wide view your home is gone
okay
and what you're trying to do is your
husband threw a grenade in the middle of
your home
he threw it in there in the in the
middle of a young girl's life at least
one if not more
um and i cannot
remotely imagine there's just one
because he got away with it
got away with it um
and your pastors failed you
probably
you're um one of the most you've
probably heard me say this on the show
one of the most damning things about
this kind of situation is you had a gut
feeling way back in the day
and you got gaslit out of your own
feelings you became the bad person for
even suggesting this happened
and you learned really quickly in your
young marriage to shut your mouth and
not believe your gut feelings
and now you're realizing oh no i didn't
trust myself and then there's a guilt
that comes with that shame that comes
all that and guilt and shame cycles us
down and then we don't act
and then you had to brave and rein the
courage to tell somebody and they failed
you they let you down
and so
what i want you to do is to walk out in
the middle of the street and turn and
look
like it's a mess
and right now
i'd be really concerned about my three
little girls or my three kids i don't
know if you got three little girls then
you got 16 year old i'd be concerned
about
my the safety of my kids
absolutely
um
finances is a thing
like i don't want to minimize that at
all
not even a little bit um there's some
harrowing data that suggests that when
couples get divorced the man's net worth
actually goes up and the woman's goes
down
so yes this is a mess it's an absolute
mess and he'll have some financial
obligations obviously to your family
your life will change
whether you end up in an apartment and
this picture of your life that you've
had is going to be dramatically
different whether you've got to leave
florida and go move with families
somewhere across the country i don't
know what that looks like
but you're pretending that your house is
still standing and it's not
okay and i'm telling you that just
because i love you and i i'm heartbroken
for you
and if i'm being 100 honest i'm really
frustrated with you because you should
have reported this a long time ago
but here we are okay here we are
um
the best we can do
when
life has helped dealt us
insanity
and we either
were abused into staying quiet we said
the wrong things we did the wrong things
i have things in my past that i was like
man i wish i could have that do that
over i wish i could do that over wish i
had to said that i wish i had like all
those things
and then i find myself here
and the only thing i can do i cannot go
back and edit the past the only thing i
can do is write something new moving
forward
and so what i would tell you is your
community
your kids
and you
are waiting right now for what you're
going to write next
the past is what the past is
when you said yesterday i think i want a
divorce how did that feel did it feel
right did it feel scary
like how did it feel
i mean
it seemed very i mean to even think you
know we've been married so long it's
just sort of
um
part of my life like and so it's well
obviously it's part of my life but
um i don't even know how to
go that route like i
it does scare me um it should it should
be it's scary
and you say you've got a family member
that's offered to step up i mean what
when you told your brother this what did
he say
oh he
he's never liked him um
um he said
when we when we first got together
honestly it was just sort of right after
some
junk that happened in college and i was
probably not in a good place anyway for
a relationship and
he was trying to tell me back then you
know it's just not a good
he's not a good guy hold on
i want to stop with you what junk
happened
um
[Music]
i was um
you know i explain it uh it was
um
to say it i guess call it rape okay um
say it say it out loud
it was i
got raped at work okay and um
hold on stop right there
i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry that happened to you
and
that makes me think all the more that
you married a predator someone who moves
in
is that fair
tell me tell me if i'm wrong i i have no
problem being wrong
no i mean someone took everything from
you
and then somebody swooped in to fix it
make it all better
is that fair
yeah probably
i'm so so sorry
i got i'm i'm heartbroken for you
and what that sounds like to me is that
your marriage has been over for a long
long time
and in a very uh trauma-oriented way
you've been going through the motions
keeping this thing up keeping this thing
up keeping this thing up
and
um
as the great vander kulk says the body
keeps the score and there comes a moment
when your body will shut you down
yeah and you're getting pretty close
right
yeah
yeah
yeah
um i have a
um like just a policy just as a way of
life it's not for the show it's just me
just as a regular old dude in my
neighborhood who goes to tractor supply
and to get chicken food right like just
as a regular guy i don't tell people to
um
except in very rare situations that you
need to get out of a situation
and i'm telling you
i think you need to get out of this
situation
i don't see a scenario where this ends
well
okay
and
i'm
feel emboldened to say that because your
brother who loves you who knows you
better than probably most anybody else
said i'll put my money on the table get
out is that fair
yeah
yeah okay
i will walk alongside you you feel i'd
love for you to call me back through
this process and i know this is a really
heavy call i know and it's probably not
what you expected maybe it's what you
expected who knows
um
your healing journey is gonna have to
include it's gonna have to start with
you learning to trust you again
and you haven't trusted yourself for a
long long time
is that fair
yeah that's fair
you're way way stronger than you think
you are
and you've had a predator for years
telling you to shut up and you don't
know what you're talking about and how
oh my gosh that's so dumb
and then you had a bunch of kids and you
just got busy
and then you got fired again and you
thought what am i doing
yeah
um
if i'm you that's all i can say i can't
tell you what to do if i'm you i would
hang up this phone and i would go for a
walk
and if you're a person of faith i would
pray
if you're not a prison of faith anymore
um i would
do box breathing around my block
which is just breathing in four holding
it for four exhaling for four
and
holding it for four again
and i would do that and walk around my
block
and then i would call my brother
and say i want to i want to meet
because i have to make some changes
and
whenever we go through a moment of
like where we realize everything's
different
um
having somebody a couple of people in
our lives that we trust that will walk
alongside us is paramount because we
don't make good decisions we don't think
clearly our bodies are in a state of
fight or flight and yours has been in a
firefight for a long long long time
so having somebody who's clear-headed
who will walk alongside you man
someone's gonna financially help out for
a season
um is beautiful and great
and he'll help you find an apartment if
that's what you have to do and he'll
help you when your husband blames you
for all this and tells your daughters
this is all your mom's fault all that
crap that's gonna happen it's all that's
coming
you said earlier you don't remember
like this has just been your life
and so let me tell you what's on the
other side of this thing
um
you haven't slept a full night's sleep
in a long time
and
you haven't felt
desired and loved in the way that
uh
husband or wife
should and you haven't felt safe in a
long long long time
well that's what i hope for you
because you're worth all that
thank you so much for the call we'll
walk alongside you in any of those tell
your pastor call me love to talk to that
deal on the phone